this is principles of reporting systems
it's talk a short talk about one
principle reporting systems namely by
temporality howdy everyone I'm James
howdy everyone I'm James thank you you
can follow me on twitter at don't use
this code we're at PI data Carolina's
it's Friday September 16 2016 so I think
I've already lost some people in the
audience so I'll start off with
something very simple a truism we as
programmers we all write reports at some
part of our job we'd like to data
analysis who might be statisticians or
scientists or mathematicians but at some
point we have to present these results
to somebody and we present it in the
form of group of a report now one
important qualification is that reports
are not data reports and data are very
different things
data can be thought of as an input to a
report the report is some distillation
of information that you present to
somebody in order to help them make a
decision it turns out that in addition
to writing reports we all read reports
but not just programmers read reports in
fact many non-technical people in your
organization read reports and when I say
non-technical I really mean
non-technical there are people who you
are providing reports to in your
organization who aren't programmers they
aren't that a scientist they aren't
mathematicians there aren't
statisticians they are in no ways
technical and in fact your organization
probably has a lot of them and they
probably make all the money in your
organization too and the reason that
they make all the money in your
organization is they probably bring in
all the money to your organization so
it's very critical that the materials
that you provide to them are valuable
reporting is absolutely core it is one
of the core support and business
functions that you can provide you do
some analysis and you find that the work
that you do is very important but
eventually that drives some
decision-making and that decision-making
comes from you distilling the work that
you do into the form of some reports
it's how leaders in your organization
make decisions naturally the accuracy of
the reporting that you're providing is
absolutely crucial if the reports that
you provide are not accurate they won't
be used in an accurate fashion and
you'll leave some very large problem so
an app
question is how do we know what the
reports are accurate or not and we can
answer this question in many different
ways we could answer this with some
statistical or mathematical analysis we
could talk about having validated our
model our machine learning model that is
we could talk about the sampling that we
used and whether this sampling
accurately captures information about
some large population but your users
aren't mathematical and while they might
appreciate these analyses they won't be
able to intuit the analyses in the same
way that you that you do you could give
them some technical analyses the report
is after all a technical artifact is a
system it's built out of code and so you
could talk to them how you're talking
about how the system is tested you have
unit tests and regression tests and
small changes in the report will be
caught if they create erroneous values
you can talk about verification methods
maybe you have some fancy static
verification and linting tools and you
could try and convince them that the
work that you're providing to them is
correct but you could even tell them we
use Pep 44 type it's except nobody uses
it because it's garbage
but eventually these people essentially
these people are not technical and so
while they might appreciate all of this
they're not going to be able to
appreciate the same way that you you do
fundamentally what they have is some
faith and confidence in the quality of
the work that you provide them in the
accuracy of those reports and it is
important that you build that confidence
in them for most non-technical users
this confidence means predictability are
these reports predictably correct
are they predictably wrong if the report
is wrong can I predict when it will be
wrong and why it will be wrong when the
reports break do they predict them do
they break in predictable ways can I
guess when the report will break when
it'll give me right values and can I use
that knowledge in order to make
decisions to borrow a term from the
distributed programming community we
want our reports to have to show errors
in a non Byzantine fashion we want them
to have a predictable model of how they
have how they show errors so that our
non-technical users can fully appreciate
when and to what degree the reports can
be used to drive business decisions but
to really drive this home I want to give
you a scenario on the 1st of the month
at midnight your system that you wrote
generated a report based on some
analyses that your that your data
scientists have done
five minutes later that report is
emailed out about two weeks later the
results are used and they're probably
used by somebody in the organization who
you didn't directly email those reports
to they're the result of some long CC
chain and some some business leaders
some CEO or some VP or some managing
director makes use of these for a
business decision it turns out to be a
bad decision because bad decisions do
happen the next day that decision is
questioned in the morning
of course mortem is conducted about an
hour later somebody says well let's just
rerun the report the results of the
report are different the report is
questioned well why is it giving
different results you know if it gave
the results then that it gave that it
gives now I certainly wouldn't have made
that decision you're brought in and
you're asked certain questions where did
these numbers come from why are the
results different if your answer is well
you have to understand how the system
works you've completely lost because
five seconds later confidence in the
system will be lost and about two
seconds after that you just start
drinking because this is just doing a
complete disaster necessarily we need to
talk about what principles are required
for a reporting system to give
confidence to the consumers of these
reports and one of the one of the
principles that I want to share with you
in this talk is a proven principle of
provenance now I said at the very
beginning that I'm talking about
reporting and not data provenance is a
very overloaded term generally we talked
about it to mean in the social sciences
where something comes from but it's used
to mean many different things there's a
lot of discussion of data provenance I'm
going to use it very loosely in this
talk to refer to a couple of specific
elements that a reporting system has to
have in order to give its users
confidence typically when we talk about
Providence or when we talk about it here
broadly we'll talk about how did the
report come to be and this can mean many
different things I think that it means
preservation reproducibility
intentionality and a term that you might
call provenience preservation in the
sense of are you preserving and
presenting input data so for example in
the report somewhere you have some
calculation you're presenting the value
X but it's actually a result of some
input
subject to some processes are you
presenting a B y&z in a fashion where
the user can understand how they then
created this value X that you're
reporting you never ever ever want the
consumers of your report to redo your
computations on a calculator the moment
they look at a value and they say I'm
not sure about this and they move over
in their spreadsheet or they take out
your calculator you've lost you want
your reports to be reproducible namely
you want to be able to capture changes
why did the report change over time why
are the why is it when I rerun the
report is for a historical date the
values are different you want to be able
to rerun the results of this report
exactly I want to say if I'm rerunning
this report I want to capture all the
information that I knew as of some date
we want to be able to tell our users why
the results of the report changed we
never want a user to come to us and say
where'd this number come from it was
different yesterday I saw a different
value when I ran the report yesterday
now it's suddenly something something's
changed and for us not to be able to
answer that when we talk about
intentionality we talk about capturing
the intention of changes that are made
to the system we want to be able to tell
you there not only that something's
changed but why that's changed and why
that's changed in human understandable
terms not oh there is this large
mechanism and we're in these processes
and you know Linux released a new
version and we did app you know pac-man
syu last night but it didn't pull down
all the packages right it needs to be
explained in a fashion where they
understand namely we did it we did a
typical rollout of patches and it failed
something that they can understand it
can still be technical but something at
a level of understanding that makes
sense to them you never want your users
to come to you and say why did this
change occur we didn't ask for that and
to not understand the actual human
reason for why something occurred in the
reporting system and finally you need
provenience and I'm using this term very
broadly typically for art historians and
archeologists they distinguish between
provenance and provenience where
Providence is the entire complete
history of an artifact where provenience
is its actual physical origin in this
sense I mean where did the values come
from oftentimes we're building reporting
systems who are pulling values from
other systems we don't generate all the
input data or we don't own all the input
data and some
times these come from other systems we
want to know where it's the ultimate
source of a piece of data was this user
uploaded data was it user uploaded on is
subject to some data pipeline where we
cleaned it up do we know if the cleaning
step went wrong do we know which
cleaning steps were applied to this data
we never want our users to blame us for
something that could have been somebody
else's problem because they won't by
that explanation you can say well the
report was wrong because we pulled from
this system and if their system had done
it that way now if you you need to be
able to tell them very specifically this
value came from this system in this
system it's this go talk to them and end
the conversation there because they're
not gonna accept a shifting of blame if
you don't have a very clear trail for
where all the input data came from in
this talk I want to focus on just one of
these aspects I want to focus on
reproducibility I want to focus on what
happens when a report is rerun and its
values change and one mechanism that we
can use to get a better handle on this
one thing is though I don't know if I've
sold you on this I don't know if all of
you really appreciate how important your
response to this question is when I
reran the report why did the values
change and so in order to motivate this
I want to share with you two actual
email threads from my time working at
the big bank I've changed some names in
here and I've obscured a couple of small
details because naturally I don't want
to kiss and tell an email comes through
from the big boss trader and it has no
body it's just the subject and it says
the sheet is broken and this is a good
email because they said at least
something was broken not it's broken
they said the sheet is broken and you
know to some of these big traders
they're very technical people in their
own domain but to them everything's a
sheet about a minute later your coworker
responds because your Kokura has been
told that we need to respond quickly to
a requests from the business because
they're the ones who are paying us and
we need to show that we're on the ball
so they respond and say well what sheet
is broken
what do you mean broken the trader
responds what's a P&L sheet the numbers
are wrong your co-workers getting a
little agitated says which numbers are
wrong I need a little bit more info to
diagnose all very reasonable things to
ask the big boss trader responds the P&L
for Wells Fargo is wrong should be
higher year-to-date
your coworker gets up you see them walk
over to the pits to talk to the traders
you hear a vigorous debate often on
one-sided debate there's some there's
some disagreement as to whether these
values are really right or wrong
your coworker comes back for the next
hour you hear him or her cursing under
their breath what maybe about 30 minutes
later there's some shock and disbelief
really seriously that's what happened
about three hours in total have elapsed
and this last email comes out the Wells
Fargo Wells Fargo had some market data
changes they were post-dated when you
rerun the report you'll get the correct
values and use those values the big boss
trader will say thanks for getting to
the bottom of this and while he'll be
very appreciative of you getting to the
bottom of it it may accept the reason
for this this has been a complete
disaster your user is slowly you're
slowly eroding the confidence of your
users in that reporting system and as
these issues occurred they're either not
going to tell you that things are broken
they're just gonna assume these values
aren't worth anything or or they're not
gonna trust that you know that this
system works correctly they're going to
put very little faith in the system that
you've built and they're not going to
use it for their decision-making which
is a very bad position to be in
considering that that's what you're
getting paid for once they lose
confidence in the system it is very
difficult for them to regain concert
with confidence in the system now I want
to tell you that the way that you can
give them confidence is to show them or
to give them a sense of predictability
to show them that you're on top of
things and so I want to share with you
another real threat with a couple of
obscured names and details this is how I
respond to this situation when it
happened and I can't show you the exact
details but I promise you these are
actual threats that I had with a couple
of details removed I got an email the
sheet is broken 15 minutes later I
respond because I thought why am I gonna
respond in one minute's time and tell
them nothing I'd rather spend a little
bit more time and tell them something
and so I responded and the email looks
just like this I said you probably think
it's broken because the socked NPL has
changed it used to be 10 million up or
used to be 12 million up now it's 10
million up in fact what I can tell you
right now is that the market data was
updated last Tuesday and junior trader
remarked it at 12 at
11:42 last night and I can tell you how
he remarked it in fact I can give you a
spreadsheet for all these changes and
why they changed the value on your
report in fact if you undo this system
which I can show you how to do you'll
actually get up eleven million year
today which is what you might expect
except if you look at the marks from the
senior trader which he did at 5:23 p.m.
last night it doesn't look like he
marked the correctly so I think as a
report stand it's what you want
here's the spreadsheet to explain it to
you 45 seconds later I get an email okay
never mind goodbye and this response
isn't just this isn't just an interplay
that since just a of me telling them
shut up and go away but that was the
intention for how we crafted these
emails we want to tell our business you
just shut up and go away don't bug me I
don't want to have these long threads
I'll answer your question with so much
excruciating detail that you will have
no ability to question the value of this
report however this is actually a very
reasonable thing to do because what I
want to tell my users is you don't know
everything about the system and you
shouldn't it's not your area of
expertise it's my area of expertise you
have your area of expertise which is
making money for this company the system
is operating as expected as proof of
this that you can trust the results of
this system I can show you exactly in
excruciating detail where they came from
so I want to tell you one mechanism for
doing this one out of many mechanisms
and one small piece that are critical to
reporting systems it's often called by
temporal modeling it's just one
mechanism to establish Providence VA
reproducibility by temporal modeling
typically means that for every piece of
data you have two times you have a
natural time in an observation time so
for example every piece of data has some
natural time so if we're talking about a
banking system you might have the stock
price of Apple last night at some value
and there's a natural time associated
what was the time for this price oh it
was the closed price for Wednesday
September 14th this measurement is
associated with some time period so we
have an observation time as well so what
when did we think the stock price for
Apple was 115 for yesterday because that
could change over time sometimes we have
post dated information it's
very very common in the financial sector
and you see it all throughout the news
in March the federal government will
really release unemployment data a
couple months later they'll revise the
unemployment data for March because they
don't have complete information about
information at any one point in time we
want our system to capture both times
what actually happened at some point in
time and also when we knew that
information what time period this
measurement was valid for essentially in
a bitemporal in a system where we do PI
temporal modeling we capture both now
this is naturally very relevant for time
series data but it turns out that
obviously not all data as time series
but the principle extends beyond just
time series data it's still relevant in
cases where you don't have a natural
time associated with this in this sense
you might so in this sense you might
find that your model your data model in
your data base has some constraints
associated with it for example you know
the user can only insert things where a
certain foreign key relations except say
your user goes offline when they go
offline they no longer receive updates
to the database and so the foreign key
constraints that they're subject to and
inserting information they can no longer
rely upon but in those circumstances you
may still may require that your sister
your user in an offline state is able to
make changes to the data system it's
able to add records remove records if
you have the client operate on an out of
view on an out of date view of the
relations you're going to have enormous
merge conflicts appear when this user
comes back online and the roads which
they relied on existing in order to add
their information to the system are no
longer there then there's going to be no
way to resolve this when they come back
online by temporal modeling is one way
that you can resolve this it's a fairly
sophisticated technique but you can
resolve the conflict by adding a temper
alley to data dependencies so you can
say this user was relying on this view
of the system at this time in order to
perform these actions and then you can
handle systems that more or less
gracefully transition between online and
offline states but more broadly than
that what I want to talk to you about is
what's called full temporality I want to
talk to you about systems which capture
the full temporalities of actions not
necessarily by temporal in the case of
Time series data
fully temporal we're capturing our
system knowledge our knowledge time we
want to capture the system times these
are called system times knowledge times
observation times there are many
different terms for them but essentially
we're capturing when we knew some
information one question is how do we do
this well it turns out that the SQL 2011
standard discusses fully temporal data
it's a topic that's brought up but it's
not really supported as a first-class
feature in any major database products I
believe Microsoft's SQL Server has
first-class support for a full
temporality and some of its tables but
it's not a product that I use I use
Postgres and Postgres actually has quite
a few extensions for handling temporal
tables the one that I like is at this
link on github it's just called temporal
tables and I want to show you an example
of how it works and what it does this is
but about what it looks like let's
create I create a table and this is real
code from a real system with a couple of
details redacted I created a table I
create all my tables after that I add a
column to that table called Assaf and
it's a timestamp range and that
timestamp range indicates when I
believed the beginning time for when I
believe this was true and the ending
time for one I believe this is true I
set a you know I populate that table
with some default value so I can make it
non null then I create a history table
so I create a warehousing table for the
historical view of the records and then
I add a trigger and that's all it is and
I actually you can notice that this is
templated this is actually the real code
I just go through every table that I
want to maintain historical records on
and I just run this in a transaction and
I've added temporality to these tables
essentially every time I perform an
update an insert an update or delete on
the original table old data will get
warehouse to the history table
transparently it ends up working very
well in practice with very little
conceptual overhead you can think of
just modeling your table as you expect
and the by temp or that full temporality
comes as just a side effect of this
trigger that's it very very simple
technique and suddenly you now know
where your data was changed in the
system you can change you can capture
every change the data set you can
warehouse
all previous versions of the data that
you have and warehousing is a very
important term
because you're not you're not adding
this historical data to active tables
that you need to have certain size
constraints on in order to ensure
performance you're actually warehousing
it so it's available for you in a
fashion that doesn't affect the
performance of your active your runtime
system now of course in order to do
something with this data you might have
to build additional systems on top you
might have to build undo mechanisms or
history viewers but the core information
is preserved and it's still there the
data is never lost if you build these
systems you can reconstruct past eight
you can tell people exactly why the
system has changed over time but what I
want to impress upon you is that by
temporality or full temporalities is not
just version control for tables when
people approach this they think well
version control makes sense for source
code because I want to see what the
source code looked like at some pass
point in time and so full temporality is
just doing the same thing for my
database tables this is true but full
temporalities she goes for beyond just
version control in fact this is one of
our core data modeling concepts and it
is a core reporting concept it is a
concept
unfortunately that is missed by the
majority of application programmers and
when we talk about programmers or we
talk about data scientists we can
classify ourselves in terms of what kind
of things we work on it turns out that
I've seen a very stark distinction
between people who call themselves
application programmers like myself and
people who call themselves database
programmers it used to be historically
that the DBA job was a rarified job a
very high profile high skill job where
you talked about the best way to capture
information in relational models not so
much anymore
right now it's most of an operational
job at most places or a dev ops job in
most places but there are people out
there who are serious database
programmers and they think about
software in a very fundamentally
different way than application
programmers I like to say that databases
grew up in a different historical
tradition than most of the programming
systems that we use an example of that
is database programmers think of a
distinction between DDL and SQL where
DDL as a data modeling language creating
tables and SQL as the query language
querying those tables
also talked about things like DML and
DCL like parts of the SQL language that
allow you to modify or change the state
of the database but for them DDL versus
SQL is a very important distinction it's
a distinction that you've actually seen
but you might not have noticed DDL
cannot be versioned you can't take a
create table operation and wisp and
store in any efficient fashion what the
previous table looked like so if you add
a column you can't undo the adding of
that column if you change the data type
of that column you can't undo that with
temporal tables and full temporal
modeling you can do that for your data
you can say rewind our database to
exactly this point in time and we can
see all the information we knew at that
point in time you can't do that for the
model itself you can't add temporalities
statement what this means is that model
changes are extremely dangerous to do
because there's no way to undo them
there's no way to restore what that
database looked like at a past point in
time which means if you build a
reporting system on top of that there's
no way for you to reconstruct the report
that was run historically one important
qualification about reports is they're
often used in their author they are
actually often used in non contemporary
as' contemporaneous situations reports
are used months days months or years
after they're generated and so there's
always a question of what I'm brought
into court or when I have to present
this information to somebody about my
profit and loss from three years ago and
I really reconstruct why I thought it
was that value and is that something
that's important yes it's something
that's incredibly important it turns out
that this DDL versus SQL distinction
means that models in database world are
static but to an application programmer
we like to say things like data is code
and code is data if everything should be
dynamic and you know sometimes I give up
certain things to add dynamic missed in
item I give up specialization ie
performance but or sometimes I ask for
it back sometimes I give up correctness
static verifiability and sometimes I ask
for it back but I want things to be
dynamic because that makes my job easier
stand I'll make concessions for the
cases of static verifiability and
specialization
performance and correctness but there
are systems that we work on that need
dynamic models if you're building a
system where the user needs the input
data that has a certain structure to it
but you don't know what the structure is
because they define that structure think
for example if you're doing a survey and
you need to you need to capture
information about a family you need to
capture information about the different
children in a family what is the what is
the SQL table for that look like I mean
you have one column for each potential
child and if you have more than ten kids
sorry oh by the way if you have more
than ten kids really sorry but what is
that what does that look like and this
is really why no SQL is popular it's not
because application programmers are lazy
it's not because application programmers
don't understand constraints they don't
understand data models it's because
oftentimes we have problems that need
tractable dynamic systems tractable is a
very key word here because we need
systems that are tangible if you go to a
database programmer and you ask him
about dynamic models and they have some
chip on their shoulder about no SQL
they'll give you some solution and it'll
be absolutely horrible it won't look
like anything that you'll see in an
intro to SQL guide the queries will be a
nightmare and you won't be able to just
look at your database in a simple viewer
and understand what's in there you won't
be able to write human you won't be able
to write as a human being write queries
for it you won't be able to use and you
may not even be able to use database
features that you want examples of this
are the many different meta modeling
approaches so you could instead of third
normal form there's like an infinity
normal form which people will approach
will tell you is a is a solution for
this dynamic modeling problem except
they end up with so many relations in so
many tables and it's impossible to model
it's impossible to understand what the
structure of your data is it's
impossible to write human queries
without at least 15 joins and you still
can't use constraints the other approach
that I've seen is EAV entity attribute
value if somebody says we're using an
SQL database a relational database and
we're doing EAV it's garbage
don't even bother just quit right there
on the spot because they're not going to
get any of the benefits of actually
using a database you're not gonna be
able to look at the data and make sense
of it it's just an absolute horrible up
row
just use MongoDB seriously you can't get
worse than eav what it turns out is that
no SQL is just a denormalized dynamic
model it's just the ability for you to
model your data in a dynamic fashion in
a denormalized fashion so you can
actually write human writable queries on
that and you end up losing some static
constraints some special specialization
and some verification but not all
because if you use something like JSON
or JSON be in Postgres you still can add
static constraints you still have
relatively efficient queries and you can
still do some verification of the
database so what I want to impress upon
you is that temporality really think
about temporalities is absolutely
critical to understanding your model and
oftentimes what a clear understanding of
temporality gives you is a better
understanding of what it is that you're
actually modeling sometimes we don't
know are we modeling static information
or recapturing dynamic information is
this a system that describes the world
or is this a system that captures
measurements that people make about the
world and they're very different things
because if you go out and you get a book
for database programmers they'll
typically discuss the former discuss how
do we build database models using SQL to
describe the way the world looks but if
you're actually doing something at work
you're probably doing the latter you're
probably building a system to capture
information measurements that people
have made about the world where those
measurements might be wrong it might
need to be corrected here's an example
the canonical example for all database
talks is the employee's table or we
capture the manager relation and salary
information so here we have a simple
table each employee has an ID they have
a name they have a manager and they have
some amount of money they make and when
people join our company we insert when
they make more money we update when they
leave the company we delete very simple
except somebody actually leave the
company and we think we can't just
delete them from the database because we
still need to know who worked at this
company historically so what do we do we
alter our table to add another column
called tenure and maybe it's a timestamp
range and we say oh now we have one more
column and this is when they started
working and when they quit working
and that kind of works until somebody
leaves the company that joins again and
you have to figure out what to do that
but you can no longer use delete you can
only use a delete statement because now
you now when somebody leaves the company
you update the table to update that
range and then somebody in the company
makes its a raise they make more money
they were making before and you say you
know for tax reporting purposes we kind
of have to remember how much money they
made before their promotion and so you
have to alter the table to say you know
this column has actually they should
probably be called active or something
like that but this we need to have one
more column where we indicate when this
record is active for so now we no longer
really update the table we just turn the
record off and insert a new row into the
database and this happens all the time
but this is absolute garbage we've just
lost two-thirds of our query language we
can't really use deletes and we can't
really use updates everything's just
insert and it's absurd additionally it's
quite unclear what this table means what
are we actually capturing here are we
capturing information about our
employees or recapturing information
about measurements that we've taken
about how our employees join and leave
this company we have a bunch of columns
here that don't matter for queries that
we really want to run like who's making
what money and who reports to whom and
we have a bunch of rows that are only
interesting for historical purposes ten
years on we have a bunch of if it's a
company where I work ten years on we
have a bunch of people in the row in the
in the database we're like I don't
really want to use his code I'm gonna
find another job and that's not very
valuable to us either let's simplify
this with a clear understanding of
temporality let's say that our employee
table has one purpose it's for queries
on active employees dead stop it only
contains information that's necessary
for us to answer questions about people
who are currently working at our company
and their current state of what they are
making and who they report to right now
today and that's it so it's used for
generating payroll in a contemporaneous
fashion we use we add a history table
and that history table using the
Postgres temporal tables has all
historical state who they work for
before well the historical table can
tell you that who and we you can tell
you that by either rewinding the current
table to a pice point in time and
rerunning a report on that
somebody who used to work at this
company but no longer works there it'll
show up in the history table as well
we might add one interesting thing to
the table we might add an enum to the
history table and in the history table
that enum might include all the reasons
why a change was made so every time we
remove an element from the active table
using a delete operation we might mark
that as a resignation and so suddenly we
can say oh the state of this active
table three years ago when we need to
generate some tax reporting purpose some
reports for tax reporting purposes looks
like this and the reason that it changed
over time was a couple of people left a
couple people were promoted some people
resigned some people change their name
and so on suddenly we can use inserts
updates and deletes what I find is often
there is a gap between the naive
approach to solving a problem and the
sophisticated approach and that gap is
indicative of a modeling issue something
where you haven't really understood the
problem that you're working on the naive
approach to doing anything with
databases uses insert update delete and
the more sophisticated approaches that
we tried before suddenly remove these
suddenly removes our ability to work on
these well there's a there's something
missing here what's missing here is an
understanding of the temporalities this
table if we fix the temporality of this
table it's only about contemporaneous
information and then offload anything
that's historical to a separate
historical table by temporarily MA or
temporally modeled then we return to a
naive simple solution we have a clearer
model we capture more data we know where
all of data came from you know why all
the changes have happened so when
somebody comes to us and say why is a
report look different we can tell them
exactly and precisely why in fact we can
be proactive about it so when somebody
says there's a problem we can easily run
historical reports before we even email
them back and say oh I noticed there was
a change here and I noticed the
reasoning for that change is a little
bit off and we can anticipate on their
behalf the problems that they think that
they're going to have we can also
capture intentionality
we know why the data the database has
changed we can reconstruct everything we
can reconstruct why something look the
way it did previously
we can establish provenance and we can
build confidence in our reports but in
the end this is a technical argument for
some
thing that really isn't a technical
problem being able to reproduce a report
really only has academic value in my
opinion obviously in some cases you
really do want to reproduce a report but
all of us use version control for our
source code and all of us have
situations where something in the
production system breaks and somebody
asks why did this break and we have
tools like blame or annotate whichever
system you want to use that tell you
this line was changed by this person on
this date and it caused this system to
behave in this fashion have you ever
said Anthony scope hats made this change
on this date and this is why the bug
appeared and somebody was like I care
about that I've never seen that happen
I've seen them say when's it going to be
fixed I've never seen them really care
about why it happened unless it was
something very major like this was done
without code review or this was done
without proper controls around but
typically the ability to reproduce the
value is mostly of academic value that
we have a better system that we have a
system that's clearer and easier to
model is really also a side effect one
thing that we might not always
acknowledge is that the quality of the
work that we do is probably not as
important as we think it's we are
insistent on doing high quality work
that's why we come to events like PI
data in many cases it doesn't matter as
much as we think it does it's important
for to us and it's important to keep us
sane and it's important for us to
express certain principles we have about
what it means to be a conscientious
programmer or data scientist but to the
business it may not actually matter that
much because ultimately our work is
subordinated to some business process
the systems that we build exist to serve
somebody not to be served and so all of
the additional sophistication that we
add with full temper ality is not about
serving the system it's not about making
the system slicker easier to write it's
about how do we better serve the
consumers of that it's about how do we
give predictability to our users through
reproducibility how do we convince them
that we know why things have changed we
have a lock on we know exactly what's
happening in the system we are able to
give these non-technical users
confidence where our explanations may
not they may appreciate a technical
mathematical explanation but they'll
appreciate knowing that you seem to know
what you're doing they may be able to
they may not be able to fully understand
at the same degree the systems that you
build the reporting systems that you
built but they might begin to be able to
intuit
and understand some of the
qualifications around when these
reporting systems failed they might be
able to predict why something is right
or wrong incorporate that into the
decision-making and make better
decisions this is what gives our work
value that's pretty principals or
reporting systems one small piece of the
puzzle by tempor ality thank you very
much
I'm James Powell so it seems like the
same sort of principle principle could
also be used for managing different
versions of the underlying software if
you think versions triggered problems is
that something that you've seen deployed
in a rigorous sense in the same way that
by temporal so I feel I feel like one
thing that we lose is that we have
certain principles theoretical
principles and one qualification on that
is we only have the tools that we have
in order to employ those so for example
if you really think about a reporting
system there are many places where
changes can occur in the code in the
data and then pieces that kind of fall
through the cracks and in many cases it
may be very difficult to reconstruct the
exact historical state of a system one
example of that is maybe you maybe you
upgraded your version of Ubuntu server
and as an example as a exercise in
reproducibility one day I tried to build
a GCC version prior to the current
version and I was able to build the
current version of GCC on a just tako
Bluetooth system with no difficulty
whatsoever one version back I could
build two versions back I couldn't build
so I said maybe if I could use my one
version back version to build two
versions back nope couldn't build it I
three versions back couldn't build I
would tell you this unless you have a
live CD for a Linux distribution from
three years ago there is no chance you
could build from scratch any of the
systems you rely upon and get an exact
copy of that and so you're relying on
some continuity of source code of
systems migrating from one from
one deployment to another department to
another deployment there is no way that
you can build a Python if you're stuck
on a desert island and all you have is a
C compiler unless that C compiler is the
latest GCC you're screwed like if you
have if you if you have an assembler you
can't build GCC from an assembler
anymore it's impossible it's humanly
impossible with enough money maybe you
could do it but but there's certain
things to just fall through the cracks
and so we just rely on that happening
there are certain places where your
system may load data from somewhere else
or maybe maybe it maybe it may not be
referentially transparent and how do you
capture all of the the gaps in the
purity of the model we do what we can